our big challenge right now is waking up
the Normie right and this is going to be
the challenge of what I'm about to say
because it's not going to apply to
anybody watches Tim cast any night I'm
talking about my neighbors all my
neighbors 92 93 Republican neighborhood
we get together every weekend it's it's
we're all having a blast we drink beer
Luke we play no play horseshoes we have
crawfish boils the kids play in the yard
it's it's it's a blast they agree with
me on all my values they agree with
everyone in this room in general
obviously we're all different in our
basic values but they're putting their
kids in college
oh man I'm so proud little Aiden got
into Stanford I'm so excited where'd
Jaden go oh Jaden got into Harvard
that's exciting the the people who share
our values are so out of touch with how
evil the traditional institutions are in
this nation the the institutions that
they previously have attended and that
they will not only still patronizing
since these institutions they'll write
them big checks